sion monsieur le ministre 'l'annonce
d'une baisse drastique du budget de la
politique agricole commune dit pat a été
ressentie comme une onde de choc
elle se traduira par une perte d'environ
8 milliards d'euros pour l'agriculture
française et pas seulement à cause du
breakbeat quels revenus pour nos
agriculteurs demain plus grave encore
dans le nouveau modèle imaginé par la
commission européenne
ce sont désormais les états qui
définiront en grande partie les
conditions à respecter pour bénéficier
des aides agricoles
c'est donc le risque d'une
renationalisation de la pac c'est à dire
un retour à 27 politiques agricoles
nationales différentes
un tel scénario signifierait toujours
plus de concurrence avec nos voisins
toujours plus de contrôle de la
commission européenne toujours plus de
complexité
le 14 février dernier les commissions
des affaires européennes et économiques
du sénat ont adopté à l'unanimité une
nouvelle proposition de résolution
européenne sur la pac
monsieur le ministre allez vous saisir
cette ultime opportunité pour remettre à
plat cette réforme de la pac mal engagée
aucun président de la république
aucun des ministres qui vous ont
précédés n'ont cédé sur la pac alors que
l'inde la chine ou les états unis
n'hésitent pas à mettre un pognon de
dengue dans leur agriculture
ne laissez pas l'histoire se souvenir de
vous comme le ministre qui aura fait
renoncer la france et l'europe à leurs
ambitions agricoles
la parole est au ministre de
l'agriculture de l'alimentation monsieur
didier guillaume sur ministre monsieur
le président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et sénatrices je voudrais
d'abord en mon nom personnel féliciter
mon ami jean yves roux votre collection
nature qui n'aide pas pas aujourd'hui je
pense que ça mérite d'être saluée dans
cette dans cet hémicycle et et et dire
et d'iran madame la sénatrice gruny que
le gouvernement partage votre votre
vision votre ambition mais si je peux me
permettre ce que vous dites n'est pas
réel la question la question du budget
de la pac et c'est pour ça qu'il ne faut
pas que vous cédiez vous aux sirènes
ultra libérale de la commission le
budget de la pac la france ne veut pas
tel qu'il est présenté par la commission
comme 20 autres pays de l'union
européenne n'en veulent pas tel qu'il
est présenté par la commission -4 9% de
baisse sur le 1er pilier -15% sur le 2e
pilier
c'est absolument inacceptable c'est la
raison pour laquelle le président de la
république l'a dit lors de
l'inauguration de son agriculture
le premier ministre ne cesse de le
rappeler la france n'accepte pas cette
diminution
cela dit il faut qu'à un mètre objectif
le budget de la pac baissera à due
concurrence du retrait du royaume uni de
l'union européenne
dire que le budget de la pac ne
diminuera pas est un affreux mensonge
mais il n'est pas question que nous
acceptions que le budget de la politique
agricole commune baisse plus que le
montant de 2,2 du retrait de l'union 2
des britanniques parce que ça serait
faire peser sur la première politique
intégrée européenne le poids d'autres
politiques
deuxième chose nous en bien repréciser
dans l'appel de madrid de ces 20 pays
qui n'acceptent pas la baisse du budget
de la politique agricole commune qu'il
était hors de question que la pac soit
renationaliser c'est la première
politique intégrée européenne elle doit
rester dans le cadre européen
et là dessus je pense qu'il n'y a pas de
sujet aussi bien la commission que le
parlement que les états de l'union sont
favorables à ce que ça reste de la sorte
et troisième point nous allons attaquer
à nouveau de nouvelles discussions après
le départ du royaume uni afin de voir ce
que nous mettrons dans la politique
agricole commune mais nous en
reparlerons dans une prochaine séance de
questions merci merci monsieur lui
[Musique]
oui merci monsieur le président je suis
contente de vous entendre
mais j'aimerais bien avoir des actes
parce que nos inquiétudes
elles sont elles sont fondées quand même
le 24 mai dernier nous avions reçu le
commissaire oettinger qui disait qu'en
fait que la france avait un discours ici
et un autre discours en fait qu'ils
aient accepté la baisse du budget donc
on est habitué au double langage
alors on a vu bien entendu au salon de
l'agriculture un discours magnifique du
président de l'agriculture mais nous on
veut autre chose et les agriculteurs
sont attendus sur autre chose des actes
monsieur le ministre